hello and welcome to this video on
playing fo risom when white ok so we get
do we get a maroc see are there are some
offbeat lines no he's going for the
straightener oxy bind can also check
when the green I think in this
particular situation so let's see yeah
this bloody line this is something that
is really interesting for black and I
haven't found anything against this when
I recently checked it's a pretty good
line really even thought again if i
should play this with black hair what's
it a while but ultimately there were
some things I didn't like yeah this is
the thing he's got some decent play on
the dark squares even though here I can
take right it stepped grateful black hmm
so it's f5 coming here no no that's not
working I want to have night b5 as an
idea membership see form ok let's double
first yep know what to do here might be
five is no real way forward
Bishop is pretty pretty bad of course is
there a way to to play here ok I'm going
for that i'm not sure about this
a bit surprised that it doesn't take it
straight away but ok maybe there is no
necessity it does not have to do it of
course but I think I I'm very much lean
towards taking it my idea was that that
this bishop at least is getting here now
ok I know it it looks like it watches
this pawn on d6 yeah it's biting on
granite in some some sort but it makes
f5 far more unlikely to happen as this
would give my bishop scope again and I
just want to play now Queen g5 doesn't
work a three and before is an idea here
but this also um yeah I don't have such
a such a stable Bishop position than any
more g3 maybe he can go h5 now stuff
like that you want to put the night on
the six year it's not something I don't
really care about this that much what
does he just want to trade I can I don't
have a look-see to available that's a
bit it's a bit awkward I don't want to
play an endgame really
you
this is six square is some potentially
nice a three what is he doing that much
looking for maybe
III root g voice awkward really is
awkward cannot go before okay as I
didn't want to play this end game
originally but didn't really see a great
alternative now a quickie for you not
it's not looking too good oh really I'm
happy about that I mean not that this is
so great for me but at least now my
bishop has got some scope on c4 it's not
doing that much right now but I think I
think you should have just played 24 you
can still play Queen default this may be
may be a good idea yeah I pretty much
have to take and now yeah FF 494
immediately hits
I don't get to the pawn twinkling
maybe gee I can go g5 and maybe take
with the king I should have gone to have
to him should have gone to have to yeah
this is possible of course you are
trying to put my pawns but okay I can
play no I cannot play that i was
thinking i can take and check in but i
can also i have to have to do this which
again is not exactly great i know it
looks stupid put them on light squares
but i don't really see an alternative is
the thing
they played that very nicely even if I
didn't didn't think f5 was good but it
was perfectly okay time morning jack I
can never check up on him
King be three yeses kingi 595 know okay
man I wasn't sure if I ever want to do
that but I do do it now 95 maybe d3 now
is the problem might very well be I know
this justice move home okay now yes d3
now that wins check no very nicely
played yeah no white resides that was a
really really nicely played game by
black Jeff this is a bit more
comfortable for him this position it's
it's just what it is yeah I was some
some decisions here are difficult to do
maybe 95 is wrong I was I was thinking
that with the bishop on c4 maybe can get
like a three before and at some point
but maybe I should just stay put I mean
this position cannot be worse for why'd
you were just staying I think he has
this the double points here they have
pluses and minuses the pluses that they
control important squares the minus is
of course that it's upset I didn't want
to do oops yeah that I've got three
against two when some in some cases i
can actually march those pawns but it
never it never happened in this game
it's very difficult also to do in this
particular piece configuration because i
don't really easily have a three-year
available at all maybe this is still
questionable i'm really not sure
so we got this and a white white does
not have much in terms of active ideas
with this I was trying to play on this
eve pile but with this air a three
before but whoop the aid is strong if i
play a three now he's got rooked e4 and
this is very annoying i cannot play
before anyway this was one thing this
was one that was my idea to play this
and put the rukon c6 but I don't get it
in I really don't can do this and then
something like Queen d6 happens and a
queen up here and and this is also not
working yeah this made me play work T 2
for the lack of an alternative and here
he is definitely better I mean
substantially better because with all
those pieces traded the night against
more yeah the night gets better my
membership this is a pretty pretty weak
piece and yeah I was I was not expecting
f5 but maybe it is good tween deform
take stakes gem and this is tricky
running the engine just thinks that this
is equal but I'm not sure about it
yeah the computer says it's a quaver i
don't know i don't i don't really don't
really believe it I mean maybe there is
some way for me to to just go build some
songs for sm like I tried in the game
basically I'm Bishop the tools it's as
Bishop each will do this to tonight d7
95 yeah probably this mechanism is doing
the trick so I have to I have to do it
differently a force the computer
suggestion with the draw why if this
happens I go on because here actually
here white actually wins okay yeah okay
this is this is actually kind of
dangerous iam okay so this move and then
night to have no bishop f7 check was
this is no progress okay so what can
actually hold this ending hmm wow wow
yeah well not in a practical game after
that it's definitely lost check yeah
even though the computer finds the way
to hold it at Sur very deserved victory
of course so black you've already played
it very nicely yeah this opening it with
Bishop b5 is something that I recently
checked and it's kind of it's
interesting it's interesting Black is
putting this Bishop on an active square
and it's not so clear what what should
do I have to check this again for my
former White games um I am I didn't see
anything great for
you have to say so i need to find find
something that's an interesting line for
black this is six specially five that's
the only line actually in the Oval Roxy
way I think that white isn't just better
without any problem here I don't really
know what's going on okay thank eyes
thanks for watching